what about not getting a job I feel like
that's where often times the experience
can be dropped yeah so feedback look the
business sees a relationship with the
candidate as a kind of lifetime
relationship so that is they might go
through a short process with us you know
this they're still part of our Network
you know and and we see that as a we're
trying to grow this big Network and and
again it's not transactional we don't
want a candidate to come in and then go
to somebody else when they're thinking
about job hunting in Hospitality that
happens relatively often we want them to
pick up the phone to us we want them to
think I've got a career coach and I've
got someone that's my pal that I'm going
to pick up the phone and talk to